yes
mr jobs you're a bright and influential
man
here it comes
it's sad and clear that on several
accounts you've discussed you don't know
what you're talking about
i would like for example for you to
express in clear terms
how say java in any of its
incarnations addresses the ideas
embodied in open dock and when you're
finished with that perhaps you could
tell us what you personally have been
doing for the last seven years
you know
you can please some of the people
some of the time
but
one of the hardest things when you're
trying to affect change
is that
people like this gentleman
are right
in some areas
i'm sure that there are some things
opendoc does probably even more that i'm
not familiar with that nothing else out
there does
and
i'm sure that
you can make some demos
maybe a small commercial app that
demonstrates those things
the hardest thing is
what
how does that fit in
to a cohesive larger vision
that's going to allow you to sell
[Music]
8 billion 10 billion dollars a product a
year
and
one of the things i've always found is
that
you've got to start with the customer
experience and work backwards to the
technology
you can't start with the technology and
try to figure out
where you're going to try to sell it and
i've made this mistake probably more
than anybody else in this room
and i've got the scar tissue to prove it
and i know that it's the case
and as we have tried to
come up with a strategy
and a vision for apple
um
it started with
what
incredible benefits can we give to the
customer where can we take the customer
not
not starting with let's sit down with
the engineers and and
figure out what awesome technology we
have and then how we're going to market
that
and i think that's the right path to
take
uh i remember
with the laser writer
we built the world's first
small laser printers you know
and there was awesome technology in that
box we had the first canon
laser printing cheap laser printing
engine in the world in the united states
here at apple we had a very wonderful
printer controller that we designed we
had adobe's postscript software in there
we had apple talk in there just awesome
technology in the box and i remember
seeing the first
printout come out of it
and just picking it up
and looking at it thinking you know
we can sell this
because you don't have to know anything
about what's in that box all we have to
do is hold this up go do you want this
and if you can remember back to 1984
before laser printers it was pretty
startling
to see that
people went whoa
yes
and
that's
that's where apple's got to get back to
and you know i'm sorry that open doc's a
casualty along the way and i readily
admit there are many things in life that
i don't have the faintest idea what i'm
talking about
so i apologize for that too but
there's a whole lot of people
working super super hard right now at
apple you know avi john guerino
fred i mean the whole team is working
burning the midnight oil trying to and
and people you know hundreds of people
below them
to
execute uh on some of these things and
they're they're doing their best
and i think that what we need to do and
some mistakes will be made by the way
some mistakes will be made along the way
that's good because at least some
decisions are being made along the way
and we'll find the mistakes
we'll fix them
and i think what we need to do is
support that team
going through this very important stage
as they work their butts off they're all
getting calls being offered three times
as much money to go do this throughout
the valley's hot and none of them are
leaving
and i think we need to support them and
see them through this
and write some damn good applications uh
to support apple out in the market
that's my own point of view mistakes we
made some people will be pissed off
some people will not know what they're
talking about but it's i think it is so
much better
than where things were not very long ago
and i think we're going to get there
if you want to see the top 10 rules
video i did on steve jobs check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there customers don't
form their opinions on quality from
marketing
they don't form their opinions on
quality from who won
the the deming award or who won the
baldrige award